Alexandra Acacio Cortez has been a
lightning rod in her first congressional
term now that New Yorker is facing a
formidable fellow Democrat former
Republican in a primary challenge that
could keep her from winning a second
term of course when Jackie Heinrich
shows us the matchup this evening
the Queens Chamber of Commerce estimated
nearly half of the neighborhood 6000
restaurants may not survive the corona
virus pandemic and one woman vying for
the district's congressional seat is
reminding voters the incumbent
congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
led the charge against what could have
been a major job maker when she threw 25
thousand jobs out I thought well she has
no idea how important jobs are Michele
Caruso Cabrera a former news anchor is
challenging the firebrand Democratic
Socialist in the June primary billing
herself as a business-friendly centrist
we Democrats made clear in the primaries
what we wanted we don't want the far
left if we wanted the far left Bernie
would have won MCC as she calls herself
criticizes AOC for voting against the
April coronavirus relief bill saying
she's out of touch with her constituents
at the height of the crisis AOC stayed
in her luxury apartment in DC with the
Whole Foods in the lobby she didn't come
home even though people were dying
although MC sees critics point out she
once called herself a wholefoods
Republican and was registered to the
party she advocated for small government
and fiscal conservatism in her 2010 book
which includes a foreword by Trump
economic advisor Larry Kudlow and she
only moved to Queens last year
previously living in a Manhattan Trump
building this woman probably couldn't
even fight Sunnyside on a map until she
decided to challenge me for the sake of
challenging me kurutsu Cabrera's
campaign is getting the backing of the
US Chamber of Commerce which has poured
millions into electing republicans for
that MCC says she'll never turn her back
on businesspeople Brett